[Musik]
das anatolische Hochland im Osten der
Türkei wir wollen Hochburgen der beiden
Kontrahenten besuchen hier in der
Provinz adiaman wählen die meisten
Präsident Erdogans akpartei und das
taten sie auch vor zehn Tagen trotz
aller Kritik an der Regierung
adiamant ist Erdbebengebiet viele waren
unzufrieden mit Erdogans
Krisenmanagement auch assistantal er
stimmte für die Opposition hat Kemal
Kilic der Rollo gewählt wie auch sein
Freund und Kollege Yilmaz Bosse mir
beide waren überzeugt dass es diesmal
klappt mit dem Machtwechsel
gab es ein Erdbeben doch überall hat
Erdogan gewonnen also richtig verstanden
habe ich das nicht wir haben es alle
nicht verstehen können
66% der Stimmen in der Provinz adiaman
gingen mal wieder an Erdogan die beiden
Ortsvorsteher sind ratlos und frustriert
wie andere Oppositionsanhänger auch
glauben sie dass viele beim zweiten Mal
nicht mehr zur Wahl gehen werden
ja das kann passieren es herrscht deine
Stimmung dass wir die Wahl bereits
verloren haben viele Leute wollen nicht
noch mal wählen gehen im ersten Wahlgang
lag die Wahlbeteiligung bei
88%. ich glaube jetzt werden wir gerade
mal auf 80 oder 82% kommen
sie fürchten dass es viele aus dem Kilic
der holu-lager sein werden die am
Sonntag zu Hause bleiben
[Musik]
wir fahren aus den Bergen in die
Provinzhauptstadt adiaman überall sieht
man noch die Spuren des Erdbebens erst
zehn Prozent der beschädigten Gebäude
sind geräumt
Burak binzet ist der Vorsitzende der
größten Oppositionspartei CHP er
versucht Erklärungen zu finden für ihre
Niederlage für den Erfolg des
Präsidenten und seiner akpartei
wissen Sie die AKP schafft es eine
bestimmte Wahrnehmung zu erzeugen als ob
Gott nur ihr Gott ist das nur sie die
wahren Muslime sind und die Bürger aus
adiamanten haben sich nach und nach
dieser Darstellung angeschlossen und sie
sagen wenn uns einer retten kann dann
ist es die AKP denn sie sind Allah am
nächsten
das chp-partei Büro wurde beim Erdbeben
zerstört in einem Café sind sie
provisorisch untergekommen
Pinzette und seine Vorstandskollegen
versuchen ihren Leuten wieder Mut zu
machen Schulung der Wahlhelfer es gab
Wahlbetrug sagen sie wir sind um den
Sieg gebracht worden schaut diesmal
genau hin bevor ihr die Zettel mit den
auszählungsergebnissen unterschreibt
nochmal täuschen sie uns nicht
wie ihr seht läuft unsere Schulung sehr
sehr gut unsere Freunde sind motiviert
und guter Dinge wir haben ihn
eingehämmert wie wichtig eine hohe
Motivation ist um die Wahl zu gewinnen
wir haben ihn gesagt dass es keinen
Grund gibt traurig zu sein jede neue
Wahl beginnt wieder bei Null zusammen
von adiaman ist es nicht weit in die
Nachbarprovinz malatia Präsident erdogan
hat sich angekündigt will Erdbeben Opfer
besuchen und hier wird klar es ist kein
Kampf Mann gegen Mann gegen Erdogan nein
es ist der Kampf der Opposition gegen
den Staatsapparat und seinen fast
allmächtigen Präsidenten
und sie verehren ihn fast wie einen
heiligen sie leben in Zelten und
Containern und halten ihm doch die Treue
von Erdogans Propaganda in seinen
Staatsmedien auf Linie gebracht
die Menschen glauben und vertrauen ihm
sehen Sie die Projekte die er geschaffen
hat und deshalb würden sie Recep type
Erdogan ihre Unterstützung nie versagen
ein Muslim sollte die AKP wählen warum
wir sehen doch was die CHP will der
Muezin soll zum Schweigen gebracht
werden unser Kopftuch wird als
Stoffwechsel kritisiert möge Allah
erlauben dass Erdogan immer an unserer
Seite steht
ist eine Demonstration der Stärke ja der
Unbesiegbarkeit
ja ist stolz auf Dich schreien sie und
Erdogans Botschaft an seinen Wahl voll
lautet seht her wir sind es die die
türkische Nation stark gemacht haben die
euch schützen vor der Gefahr von außen
und von innen und immer wieder rückt der
seinen Herausforderer in die Nähe von
Terroristen
[Musik]
seine Anweisungen von der
Terrororganisation PKK in den
kandilbergen und mit wem führt der
Gespräche mit dem politischen Arm der
PKK ein Parlament
[Musik]
Erdogan schürt Terror Ängste polarisiert
die aufgeputschte Menge jubelt sie
wollen einfache Botschaften möglichst
laut nicht leicht
[Applaus]
so leise wie hier in Tunceli der
Heimatstadt kilitzsch Davos
Tunceli ist eine Insel im Meer der AKP
dominierten anatolischen Provinzen 80%
stimmten hier für Kemal kilica von ihnen
ist
wir treffen Yusuf kilica
stolzer er gewesen als Kemal zum
Gegenkandidaten Erdogans gekürt wurde
sagte er weil das Land einen ehrlichen
Mann wie ihn an seiner Spitze brauche
ich habe mit ihm nach dem ersten
Wahlgang gesprochen ich war auch vor
kurzem in Ankara und wir telefonieren
regelmäßig er ist guter Dinge
außerdem ist mein Bruder ehrgeizig er
hält seine Versprechen ein und ist
keiner der flunker er verspricht nichts
was er nicht halten kann
die Kilic Carolus sind alle wüten eine
religiöse Minderheit noch nie wurde ein
Alevit Regierungschef in der Türkei das
ist bis heute viele gibt die das auch
nicht wollen darüber spricht Josef Kilic
stardolo nur ungern
Fanatiker in der Türkei aber das gilt ja
nicht für alle es gibt viele ehrenhafte
Landsleute die Sunniten sind und keine
Aleviten und vielleicht sind das noch
viel bessere Menschen als wir es sind
aber es gibt diese Fanatiker es ist
nicht so als ob es sie nicht gäbe
religiöse und nationalistische
Extremisten gibt es in der Türkei sogar
sehr viele sie gehören zu den Siegern
der Parlamentswahl und sie werden auch
am Sonntag versuchen Präsident Erdogan
zum Sieg zu verhelfen es ist halt nicht
die Zeit der leisen zwischen Töne in der
Türkei